- All right, I'm gonna
go ahead and get started
as more people filter in.
Thank you so much for joining us for the
"Urgency for Action at COP26:
What Will a Fair Deal Look Like?
This is the ninth in the series,
The Yale Development Dialogues,
which is a series of
virtual panel discussions
hosted by Yale's Economic Growth Center,
The Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
and also Yale's History Department.
I'm Catherine Cheney.
I'm a journalist focused on development,
and I'm thrilled to moderate
these conversations,
looking to lessons from
history and economics,
as well as policy and
practice to address today's
policy challenges in low
and middle income countries.
Today, I'm joined by several panelists.
I'll quickly introduce them,
and then I'll let them go
into more depth about their
connection with this topic.
John Haldon is a professor
at Princeton University who
directs the Climate Change and
History Research Initiative,
which is an interdisciplinary
project that investigates
the societal impact of climatic
changes across the last two
millennia.
Sunita Narain is a writer
and environmentalist
who is Director General of the India based
Research Institute for
Science and Environment,
as well as editor of Down to Earth.
Nicholas Ryan is an Assistant
Professor of Economics at Yale
whose work examines
energy policy in India.
and Rohini Pande is Henry J
Heinz, The Second Professor of
Economics and Director of
the Economic Growth Center
at Yale.
So before I hand it over to our panelists,
I just wanna provide a
little bit of context
and I'll ask Rohini to
expand on this in a moment,
as she's really helped to
spearhead this session.
But according to a report
from Oxfam, released earlier
this year, the richest 1%
of the global population
have used two times as much
carbon as the poorest 50%
over the last 25 years.
Now, climate is the top
threat to public health
and its impacts on humanity from droughts
to rising sea levels to
worsening air pollution,
will hit the poorest the hardest.
Some wealthy nations are calling
for lower income countries
to pursue renewable energy
rather than fossil fuels,
even as they themselves
continue to rely on those
sources of energy.
That leads some to call
for a just transition.
And that's what we'll be discussing today.
I was tuning into some
of the sessions at the
United Nations General Assembly recently,
and was struck by what the
Prime Minister of Barbados
had to say and really
thought it related to this
conversation.
So here's just a quote from her.
She said, "How much more
must sea levels climb in
small island developing states
before those who profited
from the stockpiling of greenhouse
gases, contribute to the
loss and damage they have
occasioned, rather than asking us
to crowd out the fiscal space
that we have for development
to cure the damage caused
by the greed of others?"
So that's just one example of
where there's a real source of
tension when it comes to
who is being asked to make
what commitments as we
look ahead into COP26?
So today we'll focus on the commitments of
high and low income countries
to address climate change
in the context of the
upcoming United Nations
Climate Change Conference
of the Parties or COP26,
taking place in Glasgow from
October 31st to November 12th.
And our panelists will
discuss climate policy from
a lower income country perspective,
and also consider who is
responsible for bearing the costs
of reducing emissions.
For those of you joining on
Zoom, we really wanna make this
a conversation.
We welcome your questions.
So please use that Q&A function in Zoom,
keep those questions coming
and I'll get to as many
as I can.
But without further ado, I
wanna bring our panelists
into this, and we'll start with Rohini.
So before we get to COP26 specifically,
I just wanna ask each of
our panelists to expand
on how their work
informs their perspective
on this intersection of climate
change and social justice.
So I briefly introduced
you all, but Rohini,
can you expand on where
you come at this question?
- So let me start by noting
the fact that the Nobel Prize
in physics today went for
work that will seem to be
important for climate change.
And I think a lot of initial
work and thinking about issues
of climate change has come from
science or from engineering
and thinking about issues
to do with technology.
What I've been interested in
is asking what perspective can
economist, especially
those who think about
implementation issues and the
political economy bring to it.
And I think repeatedly I've
seen in much of my work,
some of it with Nick, is that
we feel when we don't think of
designing institutions and
policies that take into account
both what citizens want, but importantly,
what it is feasible given
the institutional structure
in that place.
And so looking ahead to COP26,
I know there'll be many points
where lawyers are having
discussions and then many points
where leaders of countries
will have discussions.
And what I would love to
see is some more discussion,
of, how will you translate
any policies you come up with
or any targets you come
up with on the ground,
given the constraints that
exist and what does that mean
for what would happen?
So that's really the
perspective I'd love to bring
Catherine.
- Thank you Rohini.
And I agree, we'll make sure
that we talk about policies
and their impacts on the ground today.
I wanna bring John into this
and I'll note that when John
and I were first interacting
about the possibility of him
joining us as a panelist,
he talked about how his lens
on history goes way back,
which he can tell us a bit more
about in a moment.
And he wasn't sure, was
that the right addition
to this conversation?
Or do we want someone focused
on more recent history?
I just wanna say I'm thrilled
to have your perspective
looking way back.
And I know some of the
points that you're gonna make
from a long time ago are
gonna be hugely relevant to
discussions on what's coming up at COP26.
So John, tell us a little
bit more about your work
and how that informed
your perspective on this
climate change, social
justice intersection.
- Thank you, Catherine.
And thank you to the organizers
for inviting me to be part
of this conversation.
I think the big question is,
can history tell us anything
about how to address
contemporary problems?
And the short answer is, yes, it can,
but probably not in the
way that one expects it to
be able to do.
So, the first thing is that
when one looks at the past,
whether it's the deep past,
let's take neolithic societies
for example, about which we
can say, quite a lot through
the archeological record
and paleo climatic records,
stretching right up to
recent pre-modern times,
when one looks at these
different societies,
one thing stands out and
that is that resilience
and sustainability has been
a hallmark of human societies
from the very earliest times.
And indeed, most societies
have shown a remarkable degree
of resilience against even the
harshest sorts of challenges.
What tends to make a crucial
difference is a societal
structure and internal
social relationships,
but crucially belief systems
and cultural attitudes,
these are really, really important.
And I think they're one of
the things that when one looks
for example, the UN list of
SDG, sustainable development
goals, one of the things
that doesn't really have much
presence there is attitudes,
attitudes to change,
attitudes to challenges,
attitudes to social and economic
relationships and so forth.
They're there, they're implicit,
but they're not addressed
explicitly and they need to be.
And the historical record
and the archeological record
can actually tell us
quite a lot about that.
And that seems to me to be a
very significant contribution
that looking at the past can make.
- I love that, and your
point on attitudes, implicit,
but maybe not addressed in
the way they should be in the
SDGs.
I think that's well taken and
the same could be said for
climate policy attitudes and
the importance of attitudes.
I'd love to go to Sunita
next, if that's all right.
Sunita I know you're working
day in, day out on these issues
and that it's late your time.
So we really appreciate you joining us,
but can you talk a little
bit more about your work,
which I only briefly previewed
and basically what is your
key message or the things
you wanna get into today
when it comes to what a fair
deal looks like at COP26?
- Yeah, Catherine, I mean,
John, gave us an amazing
beginning.
And for me, history,
doesn't go back that long,
but a little bit of recent history.
I was in Rio when the
Framework Convention on Climate
Change was signed.
And I was there because we had
my colleague, he passed away,
he and I actually worked
on a publication called
Global Warming in an Unequal
World: A Case of Environmental
Colonialism.
And this was 1991.
And the report essentially was
a report, which argued that,
if you did not have a fair
and equitable agreement,
you could never have any
effective and ambitious agreement.
And unfortunately, Catherine,
over the last 30 odd years,
we have seen the pushback has
always been to try and erase
the concept of equity.
And to a large extent,
we did succeed in Paris.
But the fact of the matter is
it is real, you can't really
wipe out something that is real.
And it's real because even if
the rich polluted in the past,
the poor will pollute in the future.
And so unless you have a
collaborative agreement
and one which everybody thinks
is fair, believes is fair,
you will not have an
agreement which is effective.
And that actually came, and
just to add the reason we did
this report and actually
that work was because we were
working in India, and the
work in India, and I've always
said this and I've written
it, that our work on
climate change was very
influenced by our work on forestry
in India, where we understood
that the goats which people
kept in villages would eat up
any forest unless the people
who had the goats knew that
they would get benefits from
the common forests that existed.
And subsequently all the
work that we have done,
and I continue to do, whether
it's on air pollution,
where Nick has done a lot of
work, or on excreter and water,
because our work as much
more, my work is in India.
We have found the abiding
principle has been, that if it is
not affordable growth, if
it is not inclusive growth,
it cannot be sustainable growth.
In India, our biggest issue
with air pollution is because
we do not have mobility for all.
And unless we have mobility
for all, we will never have
clean air.
Unless we have clean energy
for all, we will never have
clean air.
So the air shared is
one, and that's something
we have learned because of
the horrendous pollution
that we have in our cities.
But it is very much the same
story on climate change.
So my look has been influenced
by both what I know in India,
at the global level and
also the frustration at the
global level has only
made us believe that,
understand that we need to do
much more to make the right
policies in our own countries.
- Thank you, Sunita.
And we'll get into what that looks like.
Just a couple reactions.
One thing I hope to get
to in our conversation,
when you talked about trying
to erase the concept of equity,
is how COVID-19 has really,
I think reintroduced the
concept of equity to
our global conversation
and the conversations on climate change.
So that's something I wanna
hear from our panelists on,
in a little bit.
But first I do wanna bring Nick
into this, and you mentioned
Nick's work in India and on air pollution.
And I do think I'm thrilled
to have Nick's perspective
because air pollution is
a very concrete way to
ground this all in an
example of how climate change
affects people's daily lives
and how policies can benefit
people in their daily lives
versus these conversations at
COP26, that often can feel
removed from people's day to day.
So, Nick, can you talk a
little bit more about your work
in India and how it
informs your perspective
on this question?
- Sure, so I study energy markets and also
environmental regulation.
And I think a goal of my
work is to try to break down
this idea that everything is zero sum.
A zero sum is the idea
that, if you regulated the
environment, it's going to be
costly and that will slow down
industrial growth or
that will inhibit social
and political development.
And the way that I sort of
tried to do that is studying
markets where there's some
feature that doesn't work
very well apart from just
the environmental harm
and see how that could be improved.
So for example, one of the
great triumphs in energy access
have been that in the last 10 years or so,
almost all of rural India
has been electrified.
And if you look at that from
a climate point of view,
people in developed countries
sometimes have reservations
about that, that very poor
people are getting on the
electricity grid for the first time.
But I think that that's efficient
and the right investment
to be made and that's happening
in part because of things
like drops in the prices of
renewable energy that make it
more affordable to
supply grid electricity.
So there are cases like this,
not to say that they're the
only or the dominant case, where
you can get win-win kind of
situation, where there's
investment, that investment
is sponsored in part by imported
solar panels coming from
China or technological developments
that were originally due
to scientists working all over the world,
but it actually brings energy
to poor people rather than
denying it.
And I think to me that's
a very important point
and occurs sort of paper
in 1991 was very far
ahead of its time, in terms of,
there is no progress without equity
and what you've seen now,
the transition from old
Kyoto system to the now post Paris system
is a system where countries
put forward their own targets.
And so it was exactly an
institutional acknowledgement,
albeit 20 odd years late, 20
odd years behind this paper
that we're not going to
make any progress unless
countries are making their own
pledges and trying to stick
by those for their own motivations,
which would include economic development.
- Thank you, Nick.
I wanna stick on the topic of
air pollution for a moment.
And speaking of the impacts
of COVID-19 on this space,
as we all know, lockdowns
led to improve air quality,
outdoor air quality and kind
of raised awareness of the
kinds of drastic changes that
will be needed for us to see
an impact in our surroundings.
But the pandemic also brought
renewed attention to the issue
of indoor air pollution.
So I just wonder if any of our
panelists want to expand on
why now might be a unique
window of opportunity to tackle
the issue of air pollution and
how, again that connects to
what a fair deal looks like?
Maybe Rohini, do you
wanna jump in on this?
- Sure, I'm not sure
COVID necessarily makes me
very optimistic about global
action, because in some of what
we see is a lot of inward
looking nationalism on vaccines
and those issues.
Having said that, of course,
at an individual level,
it's a point in time where
people may find its way to change
behavior that improves outcomes.
But I think one interesting
fact that, a student I know
is working on, is really
this question of how do you
trade off individual activism
with system level change?
So I think, and I think COP26
is a good point to reflect
on this, that you very
often have people making
individual pledges like,
"I will travel less,"
or "I will not eat meat."
But perhaps those changes,
sometimes you do that
and then you believe you
don't actually need to engage
in activism or you don't
need to engage in larger
system change because
you've made your trade off.
But we know that that's
not going to be enough.
So I think one thing, the
two things about COVID
that I would highlight is,
one is I think made countries
very aware that they have
to look out for their own
interests and I don't know
how that's going to play out.
And I'd be curious to
hear what boundless thing
that will do.
And then the other I think
is, it's made people aware
of their own choices and
whether that's actually going to
push them to make, even
push for a lot of change
at the system level or feel
like, "I've done my part,
I can rest there."
- Okay, two great points, I'd
love to hear reactions to.
And John, I'd also love to hear
how you think history plays
into this.
But when Rohini outlines,
COVID has made people aware of
their own choices, COVID has
made countries aware they have
to look after their own
interests, actually I mean,
can we go in history a little bit, John?
And I know this is something
you and I discussed in
preparation for this discussion,
what history can teach us
as we're sort of at this
crossroads.
And then we'll kind of get
into the impact of COVID
and bring a Sunita again into this.
- Yeah, I mean, I think the
real issue is motivating people
to want to make changes.
So as Rohini said, you can
get individuals certainly
at certain levels within a
society to make family based
or individual choice changes,
which impact their own lives
directly and they're willing
to make those changes.
But unless there is a very
substantial cumulative impact,
they at least to begin with
appear to have very little
overall effect.
But it's the motivation aspect
that I think is interesting.
Certainly looking at the
past when people are directly
threatened or challenged they'll
act and they often act very
quickly and very effectively.
And that goes right back to
ancient times where you can see
responses to floods,
cataclysmic climate events,
and so forth.
When you get rapid visible
impact, people respond to them,
not always effectively, but
often enough to enable survival
and sustainable economic
life after the impact.
The cost of course varies
according to context,
sometimes the cost can be
enormous involving great
loss of life, even though
the society as a whole might
come through it.
On other occasions where some degree of
infrastructural planning for,
for example, flooding has
taken place and there are plenty
of cases where that can be
demonstrated very clearly,
the losses can be minimized.
There's a short-term hit,
but the overall impact
can be minimized.
So motivation, then I suppose
what I'm saying is depends on
how directly it affects the
individuals or the communities
in question.
But then there's also the
point at which cultural
and belief systems intervene.
Because you can have a very direct impact
and people will continue to
deny the reality of the impact
when it comes to taking direct action.
And we can see that today in
communities which are hit,
for example, by extraordinarily
high summer temperatures
causing wildfires and
substantial economic and
infrastructural damage.
And yet there are still elements
of those communities who
deny that has anything to do
with global climate change
or global climate change impacts.
In the past, what tends to
happen, and it seems to be
a general rule is that the
people who are best able to
weather serious dramatic
challenges are those with the best
access to resources, i.e.
the social and wealth elites.
How one defines those
elites varies by social
and economic system of course.
They don't have to be narrow
groups at the top of the
pyramid as it were.
They could be much more
substantial numbers of people.
But motivating those elites
to change, tends to be much
harder because their whole
life system, if you like,
the basis for their situation in society,
and more generally depends
upon the status quo,
and asking them to alter the
status quo in a way which will
directly impact their own
opportunities is really very
problematic.
So there are two problems
really, the people who have
least invested in a society,
i.e. the people who are most
underprivileged tend to be
those who are also least willing
to make changes because they see no point.
And at the other end, you've
got the people who won't make
changes because they see the
potential damage it will do
to their own situation.
And as a historian, I really
don't have an answer to how
to deal with either of those issues.
I suspect the people who
are least privileged,
with least access to resources
are going to be easier
to persuade, to help make
changes than those who have
most to lose, which are the very wealthy
and the social elites.
Again, I want to be clear
that we have to define elites
quite carefully.
It's not simply those with
most money or those with
most power.
It has to be sociological
a little bit more refined
and nuanced than that,
but you get the point.
- Absolutely.
I thought you put it well
when you talked about people
who benefit from the status
quo, it's hard to encourage
action when that's the case.
I wanna bring Sunita into this.
So John has kind of talked about
how these dynamics play out
over the course of history.
You've talked about more
recent history and in your work
over decades on this issue.
So when it comes to motivating
change, as Rohini put it
earlier, not just individual activism,
but systems level change,
we need action across
the spectrum.
And John just outlined why
it's harder to get some people
to act than others.
So Sunita, can you just kind of comment on
whether you see this as an
opportunity and what the impact
of COVID might be on this space?
- I agree with Rohini.
The fact is that COVID is
actually, should really worry us
in terms of global action.
I mean, I don't think anyone
of us, at least I never thought
of, we would see disruption
at the scale that we saw
the last few years.
I mean, we were all locked up at home.
Some economies have collapsed,
livelihoods have gone.
We're all roaming around with
masks that we would all have
resisted, there are
locked downs of economies.
And yes, in Delhi we saw
blue skies and we celebrated
the sound of birds and we saw
the nature reclaimed itself,
but at the cost, which clearly
is something that people will
today, in my view, on one
hand, we are celebrating
clean air but on the other
hand, people are realizing
that the cost of that was just
so extraordinary that there
is also a pushed back against it.
So and it is a fact that we
have, this is the worst time
in the world, the leadership
in the world literally sucks.
We could not have thought about
a world in which disruption
of this scale and yet
to have vaccine racism
happening today, yet
to have a divided word.
I mean, what does it tell
us about the future of
climate change?
I mean, the good news is
yes, G7 goes and talks about
an interdependent world.
They've understood interdependence
that they had never
taught what happened when the
virus moves across nations
and we're all connected.
But that's what climate change is about.
That is exactly what
climate change is about.
And that is exactly why the
world has to come together
with the leadership that demands.
And as John has put it very clearly,
I mean, it is the poor
who are the victims of
climate change, but they are
the ones who do not have a
voice in the discussions.
They don't have a voice to
say that they need to do
something about it.
Let's be clear, they
understand climate change.
I mean, the farmers of
India are not, they don't,
they may not know the fancy
word "climate change,"
but they understand that
there is something at fault,
that this is serious, they
need to do something about it.
And they make the links with
the way weather is changing,
that, and if you explain a little more,
they will understand pollution.
And yes, I think there
will be a desire to change.
But there is a huge, and I
think it's much more to do with
not just the system of the
economy, but it's much more to do
with our inability to
actually do things at scale
which is different.
I mean, that's the opportunity
that I think we have
in India.
I mean, when we started
out work on air pollution,
the entire approach was, how
would you fix, and rightly so,
how would you fix the tailpipe of cars?
How would you do better emission control?
But what we realized soon enough is that,
barely 15% of Delhi drives and
there is a common air shared
and that if you have 85% of Delhi driving,
as they do in Washington,
there is no road space,
that is no air shared.
And that is why people in
the US have, their emissions,
their transport related
emissions today, have jeopardized
and brought us on at the
brink of this catastrophe.
So if people in Delhi
have to understand that,
"Unless we reinvent our mobility system,
we don't get clean air."
And the transformation
of the mobility system,
has to be managed at scale.
We are still talking about
a few battery vehicles here
and a few buses here and all
that, when CSE worked on its
first generation air pollution
reform, we talked about
moving to compressed natural
gas and a hundred thousand
vehicles moved to gas
in a matter of a year,
that scale of transformation
brought impact.
And that's really what we
need in our countries today.
And that's what we need in the world.
So, but it's also got to
do with this enormous,
for me, the biggest battle
is get the idea understood
and the possibility of change understood.
Because there is so much
mental apathy to think
of something different and
to think that it is possible.
And I think it's a lot to do
with the technology systems,
the education systems that we have,
and of course the huge vested interest.
I mean, moving to gas simple
as that was so difficult
because of the interest in diesel.
Moving out of coal in Delhi
today was possible because
we just pushed it through.
But moving out of coal in
our industries is difficult
because one, we don't have reliable power,
and two, it's the cheapest
form of fuel available.
So I think it's tough time
in the world Catherine,
a little longer answer,
but just explain to you,
it's a tough time in the world.
And COVID has actually pushed
us in my view backwards
rather than forward.
Because it is going to
be a desperation now.
And unfortunately that
desperation with mean,
we would reinvest in the
brown economy rather than
the green, even though
we will talk about green,
but we will go brown.
And that's what we have to fight.
And we have to make sure
that we can call it out.
Otherwise we are all in it for,
we'll all be saying the nice sweet words
and nothing would change.
- You're absolutely right.
- I would like...
- Please go ahead, Nick.
I was just gonna say
quickly that this framing of
investing in the green, not
the brown and the desperation,
could it lead to investment
in the brown not the green,
you have to fight it.
Nick, I think your research
kind of speaks to how.
- Well I would just like
to put some numbers.
I think probably two points,
I very highly share the pessimism
of what COVID has revealed
about the capability for
international cooperation,
but to put a number on it.
The right order of magnitude
or a number for renewable
energy investment that's needed
worldwide is something like
a hundred trillion dollars.
So IRENA, for example, says $131 trillion.
And that number is kind
of inconceivably large.
Nobody encounters a
number like that in their
day to day life.
But a basis for comparison
would be, how much would it cost
to vaccinate every person
in the world against COVID.
And that would be something
like 70 billion, depending on,
what price you'd negotiate
and the scale, but say there's
seven billion people and
it's 10 bucks a dose.
EU negotiated $12 a dose,
probably it would be cheaper
than that because, you
could bring it down.
So what that means is that the
difference between the scale,
to Sunita's point of
investment that's needed for
climate change versus the scale
that would eliminate COVID,
is about 1,500 times.
So that is how much larger the problem is,
just in in money terms.
And that's the kind of reason
to be a little bit pessimistic
if we can't get our act together
and if say the US or China
unilaterally is not
willing to step up and say,
"Here's $70 billion to
eliminate COVID effectively
from the world," then what's the prospect?
Now that's extremely pessimistic.
I'm not personally quite that pessimistic.
And I think the reason why is
that there have been sources,
there have been movements
in private sector,
especially that bring down
the cost of renewable energy,
bring down the cost of these alternatives.
So even while governments have
been twiddling their thumbs
and sort of not
accomplishing terribly much,
there has been a massive
wave of renewable energy
investment, which is in part
accelerated this sort of
adoption of electricity and other fuels
in developing countries.
So that's the sort of positive case,
which is that even as the
leaders are doing very little
innovation and falls in
costs of these technology,
as for the vaccines, have
made it at least feasible
to talk about working at
the scale that's required.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I actually wanted
to bring something up,
ahead of this call Rohini and
I were talking about some of
the things we wanted to get
into, and I know one thing
she mentioned was carbon
capture and the economics of
carbon capture and linking
to what I thought was a very
helpful piece that I'll
just quickly reference,
talking about how stopping
emissions, stopped making
the climate worse, but
repairing the damage,
and so far as repair is
possible will require more than
emissions cuts.
And that gets to the role
that technology can play,
that Nick was alluding to,
things like carbon removal,
solar geoengineering.
Rohini, is that something
you wanted to touch on
just in terms of what a fair
deal would look like at COP26,
where technology comes into
this and how it goes beyond just
stopping emissions?
- So I actually wanted
to pose the question,
because I'm relatively ignorant
and I felt our panelists
may have something to say on it.
But I feel very often right
now, we're still talking about
cutting emissions.
And so we spend a lot
of time talking about,
renewable energy and issues like that.
But we've already seen the
effects of climate change.
And even if we cut emissions
down to zero today,
we have all the scars, that remains.
And so I'd be curious to hear
from, I think Sunita, John
and Nick, how should we think
about how soon this is going
to get on the agenda?
And again, how should we
think about a just deal there?
Because that is very clearly
something that you could argue
its historic contributions matter a lot,
when you start thinking
about removing the carbon
in the air.
So maybe I'll ask Sunita
because you must have
talked about it, thinking about COP26.
- So Rohini I think that's
a very fascinating question.
And I think we need to
really work about this,
because yes we are
beyond just saying that,
we are going to be able
to cut the emissions
at the scale that is needed.
And so that's where the
whole concept of net zero
has come in to say, we're going
to live within what would,
the amount of emissions that we put out,
we are going to find ways
of being able to soak it up,
capture it, burry it, kill it.
I don't know what else we're going to do.
We're gonna find some way to
make it magically disappear.
And if it can disappear,
we will be net zero.
Now, when you look at the
proposals Rohini, and I think,
I mean, I've been one of the
people opposing net zero,
and people have often asked
me, "Why would you oppose
such a good idea?"
I mean, why would anybody
say net zero is bad?
I mean, one is bad from
an equity point of view.
The fact is IPCC said that we
need to reach net zero by 2050
for the world.
Now that doesn't mean that
India and the US can have ever
the same timeline.
I mean US with its historical emissions
and if you look at the carbon budget,
I'm not even going to go there.
I think that discussion is
today so over that we shouldn't
even waste our time
beating Donald Trump again.
And try and talk about
how India is equivalent
to the US, so I'm not
even going to go there.
But I think the big issue
with net zero is what really
exists to be able to
soak up the emissions.
Now, this is where the concept
of, again, we always keep
inventing these new words and
then people have to decipher
them and make some sense out of them,
"nature-based solutions."
So what is nature based solutions?
We're gonna plant trees and
we already have planted trees
and they're going to soak it up.
Now, where are we going to plant trees?
The vast forests of the world
and the lands of the world
actually exist in the developing world,
because it's much cheaper to plant there.
There is no cost of land.
We can plant massive
amounts of trees there.
And that's where the conversation
is going to happen in
Glasgow, which is a
market based mechanism,
bringing this together to say
that countries will be able to
pay for the sequestrations of carbon.
It's a sort of new clean
development mechanism that
is in the works.
Now, what does all that mean?
And I think that's where
the just transition must and
the whole concept of equity
and justice must be part of it.
I mean, the biggest issue
with, and I know all of you
will understand this,
biggest issue is land rights.
Biggest issue is who controls the land,
who will benefit from it.
We want to plant trees
in a country like India.
We are very clear that we
cannot have only conservation
oriented forestry, we need
development oriented forestry,
but we also know that that
money must be in the hands of
communities.
And we also need to understand
the land tenure rights,
where, will communities
benefit from it or not.
And so I think there're
lot of big issues that
we haven't even begun to understand
and already and what we need to.
And again, I'm just saying
this, because I think we need
to be able to call this out, to say,
we already gotten new
words out there, "net zero"
"nature-based solutions," all
that sounds as if it's gonna
happen tomorrow, because
these disruptive technologies
that just going to come in
and everything will disappear.
It's a tough word and we need
to understand that the poor
in the world, Nick talked
about renewable energy.
Let's be clear Nick, on
my part of the world,
solar is still too expensive
for the poorest in my country.
Okay.
And let's also be very clear,
yes, the grid has reached
across India, which is an amazing feat,
but the fact is electricity
has not, because people
are too poor to be able to
pay for that electricity.
And that comes from cheap dirty coal.
So we have to understand
that, and this is India,
then we need to talk about Africa.
So we need to get some
really hard questions there,
hard issues there, and for
once we should not allow
this discussion to be taken
over with just some nice
genteel words and some nice
things to say and we go home.
- Very powerful call to
action ahead of COP26.
Nick, I wanna bring you into this.
Sunita mentioned that there's
the rhetoric at COP26,
about net zero, nature based solutions,
these disruptive technologies,
but it seems quite
disconnected from the
reality on the ground.
And actually mentioned,
solar is still too expensive
for the poorest in India.
So price is a huge part of this.
And can you expand on what
you see as the way forward
and does COP26 get at this,
or is that really perhaps not
the right forum to find solutions?
- So it does, but very indirectly.
And politely, I would
submit, I think that the
renewable picture is
better than it has been
and it's changing day by day.
So, the numbers in India, the
most recent solar auctions
are at something like
two and a half rupees,
a kilowatt hour, and most coal
plants have levelized costs
of three and a half or four rupees.
So it possible that that
energy can actually be cheaper
and thereby enable electrification.
Now that needs a lot of, sort
of an enabling environment,
a regulatory environment
to support those things.
But the prices are very,
very close, very competitive
nowadays.
- Catherine can I just come in?
- [Catherine] Yes.
- Nick, slight, let's get the reality.
The fact is, yes, we're all very excited.
I am a real proponent of
renewable and I do believe that's
the future, but let's sort
of get a reality check.
The fact is the PLF of the solar is 20%.
The PLF of coal is much higher.
So yes, the levelized cost
of solar becomes cheaper,
but that is upfront capital cost.
Two, you do not get as many
units from a solar plant
as you get from a coal based plant.
So it is still, and let's be
clear, this is why in India,
we've not seen the commissioning
rate of solar as much as
we'd like.
And this is in spite of the
fact, this is one program
that the government of India
has completely committed to.
And rightly so, but there is
a basic issue of the ability
to pay for power.
And that's about poverty and
COVID has only made it worse,
not better.
- And the availability
is certainly a concern
and that's something that gets
worse as the scale of solar
grows.
When solar is a small
part of your energy mix,
it doesn't matter.
But looking ahead, that's
likely to be a bigger problem.
India is maybe at eight or 10%
renewable generation today.
If that reached to 25 or 30%,
it would make the power grid
much more difficult as well.
- Can I just jump
in Catherine?
- Go ahead john please.
- So earlier Nick suggested
that he was a little bit more
optimistic than some of his
rather pessimistic statistics
indicated.
And then with what Sunita
then said later on,
I'm feeling more pessimistic again.
But it strikes me that one
of the framing questions
that we need to be asking as well,
which everyone's aware of
is the geopolitical aspect.
Because on the one hand we
have, we're asking some of
the right questions and
we're actually developing
some of the correct answers
and we were costing them
and we can see what they might
achieve if we can apply them,
but actually instrumentalizing
them, it meets a major block.
On the one hand with geopolitics
and the competition between
state interests, whatever
the politicians at COP26
might say, they all have to
consider their own particular,
local political interests
and political survival as
individuals on the one
hand and on the other,
we have below the level of states,
but not really much less
visible, competing global
multinationals.
We're almost at the stage now
where we have an Asimov like
world run by giant corporations,
which we know can have enormous impacts,
particularly on less powerful
states in terms of influencing
them.
And one only has to think of
the way in which from the point
of view of estate, China
is beginning to affect the
economies of many African countries now,
both to the advantage of those
countries on the one hand,
but certainly to the
geo-strategic advantage of
the People's Republic
of China on the other,
which then complicates the
world geopolitical situation,
increases tensions between
superpowers and so forth.
We all know that.
How do we build that into
our framework and how do we
address those questions?
Seems to me to be a fundamental problem.
And from the historian's point of view,
that's always been even before
people were globally aware,
but let's say in more
recent pre-modernity days
in the 17th and 18th centuries,
when European imperial
states were understanding
the nature of the potentials
for global power and control.
Even at this point, these
factors were directly impacting
on local and regional
sustainabilities and their economies.
And I'm wondering the number
of intersecting problems
that we're having to confront
in order to thrash out
some simple policy decisions
and obtain the investment
we need to contribute towards
that hundreds of trillions
of dollar costs, seems to
me, not quite insurmountable,
but frighteningly problematic.
And as long as we're
working on a highly divided
nationalistic geopolitical
scenario, that's always going
to be a major sticking point.
Whatever the promises
that might be held out
to an international conference
or congress such as COP26,
behind that, as soon as the
people who do the speaking
and make the promises go back home,
they're confronted by
their own local realities.
And we all have seen on at
least three occasions since the
1960s, how many of the
promises that were made
were simply written back
on really very rapidly.
- I wanna bring Nick into this
just because actually Nick
has to go teach an undergraduate
class in just a moment,
which we all certainly understand.
But Nick, I saw you nodding
along and I just love any
reaction you have or just final thoughts.
And then we'll bring in some
questions from the audience.
- No, I think professor
Haldon's point fundamentally is
it depends in this pledge and
review in the nature of the
COP on the interest of
the individual countries
and what they will sort of
be able to carry out at home,
and the US is the worst
example of a laggard,
because its commitments
have always been very modest
if not sort of altogether negligible.
And yet it's not even lived
up to the commitments it made,
for example, the Green Climate
Fund, which was one of the
mechanisms conceive to
transfer resources to
developing countries for adaptation
and mitigation investments,
was supposed to have
a headline value of a
hundred billion dollars.
Till date there's been something
like 8 billion committed.
The US initially offered
three and then gave one.
So, it's not promising enough
and then not living up to
promises.
And so we've reached at odd
point in the COP rounds where,
the sort of historical
countries responsible for mostly
emissions have done very little
and yet India has adopted
a call, has set these ambitious
renewable energy targets.
China though leading the
world in carbon consumption
has also sort of increased
dramatically its investments
in renewable energy and
is supplying the world
with solar panels to get this done.
So I think this is a time
where the US and Europe
in particular need to
sort of walk the walk
and an ounce of walk is
worth a pound of talk
for the next round to show
that they're actually serious.
Yeah.
- Thank you, Nick.
I wanna go ahead and move
to some questions from our
audience.
And this is something we've hinted at,
but this question tackles that head on.
So this is from someone who's
doing a study on climate
justice and capitalism and
asks whether our speakers could
speak to the global capitalist
system and whether it
disenfranchises the world's
most vulnerable communities
in terms of climate justice.
So I want to begin with Rohini and Sunita,
and then perhaps we can go
back in time a little bit
and talk with John about
really whether addressing
inequality is necessary
when it comes to solving
the politics of climate change.
But first this question on
capitalism and whether it
disenfranchises the world's
most vulnerable in terms of
climate justice.
I think it tackles what
we're discussing head on,
and maybe we'll begin with Rohini on that.
- Sure, it's hard to not agree.
So I'm trying to figure out
how do I give a more nuanced
reply to that?
So maybe a question think
to about is, why is the
climate different from all the
other ways in which the poor
are disenfranchised by the
global capitalist system.
And again, to go back to one
thing that Sunita talked about,
which is really the
tragedy of the commons.
So I think Sunita talked about,
thinking about communities
and forests and it is the case
that the poor the world over
are much more dependent
on agriculture, on land.
And those are systems
that are particularly,
one that do particularly badly
if, then there are poorly
defined property rights,
for instance, over water,
or for instance, if someone
can come along and say,
"I'm going to grow Palm oil
because there's a big market
for it."
So, I think perhaps one way
into this question or thinking
about climate justice is really asked,
can we start thinking about
the ways in which we give
legal rights to the world's
poor communities on these lands,
because that's what capitalism asks.
It asks us to trade in a
marketplace where people have
rights and they can trade.
And we very often don't
give those depending on
natural resources, the same
kind of rights as someone say,
buy a house in New Haven.
- Sunita any reactions to
that or this part of question?
- Yeah, no, I think Rohini said it,
I mean, only difference I have is only
some of those rights would be
a little complicated because
it's not just private rights,
it's community rights.
And the problem with the climate
change and the problem with
forest and grazing lands and
water bodies is the fact that
we need to redefine the system
of rights and move beyond
individual rights.
We need individual benefits,
we need cooperation,
but often rights have to be
held almost like a trust.
And that's where the problem
with the modern capitalistic
system has been, that it
only understands one kind of
right.
And that really is part of the problem.
But I think one of the, and
Catherine I'm also struggling
and trying to, I don't want
to go down in your panel
as being the most pessimistic person.
So I'm also trying to, and
this question gives me a way
to be able to answer, to
say to me, I work in India.
My entire work is here fighting
for clean air, clean water,
garbage, forests, all the rest of it.
And I see progress.
And so let me be very clear.
I don't see the same level of
progress that I would like,
because then I'm an activist.
I want more than I will get at any time,
but I see more progress in
India than I see globally.
And I see more progress here
because of the imperative of
change.
I mean, we are today
increasingly seeing NIMBY
on its head.
"Not in my backyard" has always
been "not in my backyard"
of the rich.
And it is the poor whose
lands the mark has gone to.
And that is where John
talked about the elite,
broadly in my view it's the
people who call the shots
and say, "Not in my backyard
that you have an incinerator,
a coal-based plant, a waste
disposal system, whatever."
It always moves to
somebody else's backyard.
And that's the classic problem
of the way globally we have
also managed pollution.
And it's not the US ,it's
China which is producing it
or India.
And in India, it's produced
because it's so cheap.
And why is it cheap?
Because lately any environmental
conditions are given
a go ahead.
I mean, they don't need to account for it.
Now I see that changing here
because of the fact that you're
getting more and more what I
call "the NIMBY of the poor,"
where it is the poor who was
saying, "not in my backyard."
Not in my backyard can the
city of Thiruvanthapuram
and Kerala dump its waste, small thing.
But the fact is the poor
village woman is saying that,
and the villages are getting
together and saying that,
and that actually turns the
entire waste system on its head,
because if the rich can dump
their waste in the lands of the
poor, they need to dump it
on their own front yard.
And if they have to dump
it on their own front yard,
they even have to clean it up.
So I think to some extent,
this is the power of democracy.
This is the power of being
able to give a voice to people
and the rights to people
to be able to ask, demand.
And that's where the change
is coming in my thought of the
world that's it.
So that's the biggest trigger for change,
real change that we are seeing.
So I see if you can do that globally,
I don't say it's possible,
but nevertheless,
I see that as the way ahead.
- Thank you, Sunita.
We have questions coming in
and we're quickly running
out of time, but John, I
did wanna come back to you,
not necessarily to talk
about the capitalist system
as it exists today, but this
connection between inequality
and the politics of climate
change and how we can make
changes and design institutions
that address, not just
climate change but inequality.
- I think the first thing
is that if one looks at the
capitalist system as
a global system today,
then it is a deeply oppressive
system and an excluding
system in many respects.
And in theory, one can theorize
a capitalist world system
that is less inegalitarian.
But I think by its very nature,
that sort of market economic
system requires the necessity
for some people to be kept
if you like, at the
level of being excluded
in some respects, from a
range of different types
of resource and access to
resource and facilities.
On the other hand, it also
depends upon consumerism.
And one of the major problems
that we, it wasn't mentioned
earlier, but it's a key
issue, is the mass consumerism
of the privileged parts of the world.
Which is one of the major
drivers for both air pollution
and industrial output.
So it has both good and bad sides,
how to square that circle,
that's a whole different issue.
Do we need to get rid of the elites?
Well, it's a nice idea I
suppose, if one isn't a member
of the elite.
But we'll always need to
either choose, elect, select,
or somehow have people who
can speak for the larger
majority, however they're
selected or elected.
And that takes us to a whole
different ball game about
political systems and so forth,
which we probably shouldn't get into.
I think what one can aim for
though, I mean, the real issue,
which I've mentioned in our
private discussions before,
is baseline inequality.
What makes societies in the
past least able to resist
substantial environmental challenge.
And the greater the degree
of baseline inequality,
the less resilient and the
less sustainable they turn out
to be.
It doesn't mean to say
that in the short term,
some elements of those societies
don't do very well out of
change, and those elements
are usually elites.
But it does mean that the greater
the distribution of wealth
across the society, even
if you have an elite
and an underprivileged group
at the other end of society,
the greater the degree of
distribution of wealth,
the more flexible, the more
resilient, the less brittle
a societal system tends to be.
And that means it can overcome challenges,
quite substantial challenges,
both short and long term
more successfully.
Again, there are always
costs to resilience.
You can't have resilience
without paying a cost.
That's the basic message that
certainly we learned from
the historical record.
Maybe in the future that can
be different if we organize
our resources and access
to resources differently
from the way we currently do.
So I think maybe getting rid
of elites is a nice idea,
but it's not likely to
happen anytime soon.
But what we can do, and we
can demonstrate that this
is possible in certain
sectors of the world today,
is have a much better
distribution of social wealth
and access to social wealth and resources
than we currently have in many countries.
And it's that extreme
difference between the very,
very small, super wealthy
elite and a much larger,
massive people who are more
or less entirely excluded from
the possibility of achieving
access to the resources
that make for a healthy
and sustainable life.
If we can get rid of that difference,
we already take a
substantial step forward.
- Thank you John.
I wanna end with a
question from the audience
and perhaps even broaden
the lens of this question.
'Cause I think it's something
we should all consider
and leaders at COP26 should consider.
But the question is, what
are steps you think youth can
or should take to engage in
climate activism in a more
class/wealth conscious way?
So how can youth, or how
can we all take steps
to when we think about climate,
think of it in terms of
a fair deal, based on all
of the dynamics we discussed
today.
So with just a couple
minutes left quickly,
I'll go to Sunita and John, and
then we'll wrap with Rohini.
But Sunita, any reactions
to that great question?
- Yeah, I just want to say Catherine,
I'm so impressed by the
words of the youth of today.
And I have to say that I
have been a climate activist
since 1990 and it has
been a very tough job.
And I have literally been
in tears in many meetings
to try and get the word of
equity, justice and to get people
to understand why it is important.
And I still believe the
establishment, NGO who work,
civil society who works on
this, I fail to get them
to understand.
But when I see the voices
of the youth today,
they understand, they're
rooted in the politics
of climate change.
And I'm seeing a diversity of
voices from the youth as well.
So I think hats off to the
youth of the world today,
not only are they talking to the power,
but they aren't rooting
the conversation on climate
in the reality of climate,
in the politics of climate.
And that is critical for us to move ahead.
So I would only say, do
more of what you're doing.
- Thank you Sunita.
And I believe that question
came from a Yale undergrad.
So thank you for that.
John, any reaction to that?
- Well, yeah, I think younger
people have really set the,
established an initiative
and I can't ever claim to be
a climate activist as such,
although I've always been
politically active and I
guess nowadays the two things
have to overlap to a very large extent.
But I think some of the movements
that one sees such as this
Extinction Rebellion some of the other
youth based movements, but
which have also attracted
a lot of support from older generations
and which are cross social class as well,
the people involved are from
working, class middle class
backgrounds, of course
different cultures define social
and cultural class in different ways.
When one talks about
middle class in America,
it means something quite different
from when one talks about
middle-class in England, for example.
Nevertheless, the activism I think spreads
and it's contagious,
and it's a good thing.
And we have to accept
that activism has to be a
broad church.
There are gonna be some aspects of it,
which we as individuals might not like,
and other aspects which we
feel are not activist enough.
But the crucial point is to
make an impact and to force
people to pay more attention
to the problems and issues
that we face.
And that's what political
activism has always been about.
It hasn't necessarily been to
directly bring about a change
in itself.
It's been about attracting
enough attention to persuade
other people to get involved
and realizes an issue
and do something about it,
either in their voting patterns
or in their daily lives or
whatever it happens to be.
- Thank you, John.
And Rohini, your thoughts
on this, to close this out.
- I know we're out of time,
so I'll keep it short.
So I think I would just say
something that was perhaps
implicit in what John was saying, which is
you can't ignore the state
or the politics of the state
in the end.
So I think a lot of activism
is great and groups like
Extinction Rebellion are
great, but it reminds me
in development, we've had a
long history, in fact, even at
Yale, like these are the
most active student groups as
effective altruists.
And I think the thing I always
tell them is, "You have to
engage with the state."
I mean, in the end, it isn't
about, there isn't that much
foreign aid in the world
for poor countries.
It's about getting them to
get their state to work.
So I think the youth are doing
great things and they should
just make sure they vote
and the push for change
within the political system as well.
- Thank you Rohini.
We are out of time.
I wanna thank you all
so much for joining us.
Again, this conversation
is part of a larger series,
"The Yale Development Dialogues,"
and our next event will
focus on health equity.
It'll take place on
Thursday, October 28th.
So stay tuned for details on that.
Thank you to our co-hosts the
Yale Economic Growth Center,
Jackson Institute for Global
Affairs and History Department.
Thank you so much to our
panelists and thanks to all of you
for joining.